you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is a game
from the 1958-59 us championship between
Bobby Fischer playing as white and
Samuel Reshevsky there are a few things
highlighted in this game for one or the
main one there's a very sharp tactic
really early on in the game this game
lasts 42 moves but it's over long before
that and once one side has an advantage
a material plus in this case we see that
common strategy of making even exchanges
and simplifying the position and also
being mindful that we can invest some
material back in order to keep our
opponent off balance and uncoordinated
so let's see what took place in this
game again Fischer on the white end he
opened with e4 Reshevsky replied with
the Sicilian defense Knight f3 knight c6
we have an open Sicilian black prepares
a king side fee and keto and now
anticipating this natural pressure on d4
it's Bishop e3 so more natural moves
coming in getting the minor pieces
developed and getting castled Bishop to
b3 is the first maybe not so natural
looking move but its aim is to sidestep
a common tactical motif that black has
available for example if white castles
here instead of Bishop b3 this is the
combination I'm referring to taking on
e4 and following up with d5 short story
here is that black will regain that
material and have benefited as a result
of that combination since they have
eliminated whites only central pawn one
other detail I'd like to emphasize here
is the timing of this combination of
moves taking on e4 and then playing d5
you'll notice this here after Bishop c4
this is the first instance where it may
seem that black going for this capture
but it's not on for as long as the black
King remains on his home square if black
goes in for it right away you'll notice
after d5 there's Bishop b5 and there's
going to be a problem on c6 pawn takes
Knight there's Knight takes Knight if
you're immediately recapturing black is
going to end up in a fork one other
detail I'd like to actually take this
just one step further after Queen takes
Queen for the moment let me just make
this inferior King takes Queen move this
right here is a common configuration
that we could see arising out of many
openings it's important to know how you
can get the piece back in this case
again taking like this you end up in a
fork the trick here to get the piece
back would be first a six kicking a
bishop to this a four square and then
interposing on D seven with the bishop
and maybe even in some cases you could
do so with the Queen taking advantage of
again this unprotected piece on a four
this is of course not the same case here
taking what the king is not best taking
what the rook is because now after this
a six idea to get the piece back well
that's just falling for me and one so my
main point here was to not only
emphasize the motif itself but the
timing of it okay black castle Bishop b3
and in the game we saw a serious blunder
already by move eight blacks move Knight
to a5 is not good can you spot why that
is the case if you'd like to go ahead
pause the video see what move or
sequence of moves you would play in this
position okay the move here was e5 and
before I go any further let me just
emphasize that d6 would have been better
to open up the diagonal for the bishop
and stop a 5 but black was trying to go
quickly for the bishop pair trying to
take out that guy but II 5 is now going
to oppose blacks on
serious problems what is he going to go
to the edge G for he's dead what about
here
well we'll soon see what happens if he
goes there let me just first point out
that this would have been the best
continuation for black to go in for the
rook give up the two minor pieces white
stands better still but in the game
after E 5 it was Knight to e8 and now
this is where that sharp combination
comes into play here if you'd like to
once again go ahead pause the video see
if you can find White's next stunning
move alright the move here is Bishop
takes f7 what a shot
regardless of how this Bishop is
captured White's going to follow up the
same in the game it was king takes
bishop and in comes Knight to e6 taking
advantage of the fact that this Queen is
unprotected and all these squares are
now covered with the minor pieces if you
didn't spot this Bishop to f7 move one
of the things that could have maybe
helped you to see this combination of
taking on f7 and then following up with
the knight to e6 is to realize what
Black's last move was doing it is
interfering with the coordination of the
Queen and rook as soon as he arrives on
ei the Queen on d8 is unprotected this
is often signalling possibilities for
tactics when you have an unprotected
piece sohow Bishop takes pawn was played
King takes bishop and now Knight to e6
if you take like this the move played in
the game well we're going to get the
Queen why wasn't King takes Knight
played well it's going to run into a
main six with check check another check
if you go here that's me and if you go
to one of these three white plays the
same move Queen to g2 and now there's
three different mates can't stop all
three so in the game what was played is
pawn takes Knight and now the Queen is
we enter this already lost position
after 12 moves White has Queen and black
only has two minor pieces to show for it
so the plan from here is basically to
just exchange pieces even exchanges
you'd really like to as white exchange
off a pair of rooks black will find it
much more difficult to stay coordinated
that is a very important thing to do
when you're without the Queen if there's
some type of imbalance in the game
without two rooks on the board this is
going to be very difficult for black to
remain in a harmonious position so white
is seeking exchanges hitting at e6 c3 is
just a nice restricting move
keeping the knight out of these squares
the d4 square is the main one here
especially now with this pawn on e5 so
it's just boxing out that night this
pawn on c3 is boxing out the knight
white gets a rook involved we have the
bishops coming off soon enough after
Knight to e4 Queen takes pawn the knight
jumps into d6 he's intolerable there
goes the dark square bishop and now we
have b4 looking to disrupt the
coordination of blacks pieces the knight
is kicked the rook backs up he
eventually wants to get to the c7 square
this is covered this is his destination
trying to get to see the seventh ranked
Knight f7 rook to c5 trying to get some
play here for the rook but that's just
going to be closed right down with b6
this gives up the c6 square but white
has a good follow up here Bishop c6
looks to just string everything together
but you have to recognize that this is
just too strong for white to deal with
very strong coordination of pieces and
this is what I was referring to in the
beginning the game with investing some
material back that Bishop cannot be
tolerated just get rid of him and on top
of that you have a past pond so there's
even even if for some reason this pond
wasn't around this is something to still
certainly look into giving that rook up
for the bishop and disrupting the black
ponds making coordination making life
much more difficult for the black side
in this in this case it's all the more
appealing because of this past pond but
just recognize yes you can invest the
material back we got B seven in black is
on the defensive white scoops up upon
this pond will be won back but don't
forget about this eight pond because
it's the one who have the final say in
this game after rook takes rook takes
Queen a8 it's at this point that black
already throws in the towel the game's
over there's nothing to do there's no
good way to coordinate the rook and the
knight here that would stop the ape on
white has a flight square you can throw
this check in king h2 this pond will run
and there's no way that you could stop
him right you could maybe somehow get it
if you could just let's throw some moves
in here suppose I don't know Knight here
the pond advances the rook gets behind
maybe the knight tries to get here but
you'll notice I mean this isn't a stable
square this pawn on c4 can always offset
the one on c6 the knight has no good
safe square there's no good way to
coordinate to stop this past punt and it
is it is again at this point after Queen
a that Reshevsky simply resigned so
that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it take
care bye